when last we left our english colonists
at jamestown things were finally
starting to go their way lord delaware
had successfully led english forces
in their war of extinction against the
nearby algonquin tribe the powhatans and
john rolfe
had discovered that
virginia was a perfect place
to grow tobacco
so even though they didn't find gold in
virginia they found something that was
almost as good and that was a
luxury commodity that people in europe
were very eager to buy but tobacco was
incredibly labor-intensive
to grow and process
so in this video let's talk a little bit
more about what that need for labor
meant as the virginia colony began to
grow now in the last video i mentioned
that the very first ship bearing
enslaved africans arrived in jamestown
in 1619
so just 12 years after jamestown was
founded africans had been brought to the
area so this shows that enslaved
africans were some of the very first
people who weren't of native origin in
the new world and would help shape the
english colonies pretty much from the
very start
but even though there were enslaved
africans
in virginia that early
the system of broad race-based slavery
that will really characterize the
american south up until the civil war
didn't get started right away and there
were a couple of reasons for that one
was as we've mentioned many times it was
not particularly healthy to live in this
area
you can see here this is pretty much all
a giant swamp
to this day you know some people joke
that one of the reasons that washington
dc was founded here in this area of
virginia is that it is so unpleasant to
be there they thought it would keep the
american government smaller because
legislators wouldn't actually want to go
to the capitol so a pretty good number
of people who came
to the new world in these early years
died of mosquito-borne diseases so swamp
standing water mosquitoes
leads to epidemics
so say i'm an english planter and i want
to plant a lot of tobacco many acres of
tobacco
so i'm gonna need some people to help me
now i have some choices i could
purchase an enslaved african person
from one of these ships and that might
cost me hundreds of pounds
slaves are pretty expensive and since
it's such an unhealthy environment in
this area there is a reasonable chance
that any person that i purchase
might die within a year or so and then
i'd lose my investment so this is a
pretty cruel and terrible form of
economics but if you're a planter in
this time period this is exactly how
you're thinking now my other option for
help is to bring over white laborers
from england and these are called
indentured servants
so perhaps there is a
young man living in london
he has lots of older brothers so he's
not going to inherit anything he doesn't
have much in the way of economic
opportunity so he thinks i could go for
a new start in the new world but i don't
have the money to pay my passage on a
ship across the atlantic so what the
planters would do is they would say all
right i will pay
your fare across the atlantic and maybe
that's
15 pounds say and in exchange you will
work for me
for a period of say three to seven years
some indentures were shorter than that
some were longer but this is a kind of a
general guideline of how long they might
work and at the end of that three years
you will get land of your own
and
i will give you some tools and clothes
things you need to succeed and then you
can be your own planter
so this was a pretty good investment if
you were a young person without many
opportunities in england there is only
one problem and it's the same problem
we've been talking about all along it's
that this is a swamp full of mosquitoes
and you are quite likely to die in
virginia so this actually turned out to
be a pretty good deal for the planters
who were there early they also took
advantage of something called the head
right system
which meant that
they got
50 acres
of land
in virginia and of course this is just
native americans land that they're just
appropriating for themselves but that's
a whole separate issue so you got 50
acres more land
every time you brought one person over
from england so if you could afford to
bring more and more of these indentured
servants over from england you could
amass
huge huge amounts of property just
gigantic tobacco plantations and early
on in the history of indentured
servitude very few
of the servants of pretty small
percentage actually lived to finish
their indenture and to make good on this
promise of land for themselves and
tools and clothes to get started so this
very quickly begins to build a social
structure in virginia where there are a
few planters
who are extremely wealthy
who own lots of land
and then there's everybody else there's
a large number of indentured servants
who've only been there for a couple of
years
uh who may or may not live to see out
the end of their indenture so this is
kind of a large lower class
and then there are a handful of small
farmers who managed to live through
their period of indenture are now
getting started on their own
and then they're just a tiny smattering
of enslaved africans
so just a few slaves in virginia this is
in the early years of the 1600s so how
do we get from a world where the vast
majority of workers in the southern part
of what will become the united states
are white to a world where the vast
majority of people working on
plantations were enslaved black africans
we'll talk more about that in the next
video